bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
Friday coming to you live late 12:21
recording this while while she's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get our lunch money right normally
we're trying to come to you at noon but
a little late today the beautiful miss
Polina has on her Easter best it's a
whisper get mine name you know it's a
week late for us Easter but in Bulgaria
this sunday is Easter correct and we
went today and got some coffee and I
brought us a little friend so that while
we record we can all talk about our
chocolate bunny who I'm gonna eat later
it's little fellas gonna go on my
stomach but while we're waiting for that
to happen why don't we get started with
what is cancelled everything is
cancelled I feel like 2020 should just
we should just cancel at all there's
nothing left and de Blasio keeps
Blasio's the New York City Mayor yes he
keeps canceling the Brooklyn half
marathon summer stage in Central Park I
mean what else is there to do this
summer okay so they're basically
canceling all of the events through the
summer in New York City
Facebook also canceled all of their in
person large events anything that has
more than 50 people all the way through
June 2021
when is Facebook's f8 take place usually
in the fall I believe if I remember
correctly so that's canceled done and
people are gonna keep canceling things
right I mean like do you see that
changing anytime soon I mean I hope we
don't have to cancel our wedding again
postpone reschedule okay is that all
right yes all right what's next dad okay
these obviously plain account with the
topic say we have canceled and we have
dead and we have a Easter Bunny so the
IRS is sending dead people stimulus
checks of $1,200 and the problem with
this is that if you guys remember a few
days ago we talked about how that
volunteer firefighter got 8.2 million in
his account so now dead people are
getting IRS tracks they print so much
money even dead people getting rich
do you think this is a problem because
the money's running out like if you if
you send a check to a dead person's
account can you get it back it's all
funny money yeah they can get it back
it's all funny money that's what's going
on they can print whatever they want it
doesn't matter listen here's the deal
there's 641 billionaires as of 2019 in
the United States why do I know that
don't ask for the 641 billionaires in
the US if they keep printing money like
this we're all gonna be billionaires
literally brawlers have a billion
dollars but the thing is that they can
print away the value of the money and so
a billion dollars is the equivalent of
20 bucks it's like in Zimbabwe literally
they have a hundred trillion dollar note
there's a note a piece of paper that is
worth 100 trillion dollars and so in the
US if they keep doing this it may not
happen tomorrow I don't think it will
next year five years ten years but at
some point you end up inflating away all
the value and so what ends up happening
is since 1913 99% of the purchasing
power of your dollar has evaporated
meaning that that dollar bill although
it says one dollar on it still it
actually can buy 99 percent less goods
right and so it doesn't help when
they're little just printing so much
that they're just sending money all over
the place even to dead people
yeah but I feel like they have to send
the money so fast that there's probably
very little time for them to go through
the errors and check what they're doing
which should be dead people somebody
should get their state right I guess but
the I feel like if you're sending out
checks to people who need it right now
for their families etc wouldn't you
account for that yeah but what if you
died yesterday they don't know that yet
it's all just information hey man they
print so much money even dead people
getting rich all right but this leads us
to the balance sheet you know what's
going on with the Fed balance sheet I
don't why don't you tell us what's going
on with the balance sheet yesterday they
didn't know how much money they had
literally that's what happened so
yesterday they were supposed to be the
weekly update for how much money is on
the feds pension the Federal Reserve so
Federal Reserve is the central bank of
the United States and it has a balance
sheet think of this as a bank account
and every week they update how
much money is in their bank account
rather on their balance sheet recently
they have been printing a lot of money
it's called quantitative easing and
they've been adding that money to the
balance sheet so in the last about 30
days ago or so a month ago the Fed's
balance sheet was four trillion dollars
give or take since then in the last
thirty days they've added two trillion
dollars so 50% increase in their actual
balance sheets they're now over six
trillion dollars which means that every
week they're literally adding hundreds
of billions of dollars right and we
throw these numbers around but like
billions and trillions those are massive
numbers but even the difference between
billions and trillions is big and we
just throw them around B's and T's or
whatever so what end up happening
yesterday is they literally said we are
gonna have to delay the announcement of
how big our balance sheet is for data
issues then it couldn't figure it out
and so this is what happens you put so
much money you're gonna know how much
yet it says this is a crazy fact it is
now the equivalent of mostly 30 percent
of the size of the US economy before the
crisis struck do you think that's the
highest what they call a Fed balance
sheet to GDP percentage in the world now
who do you think has the highest I have
no clue Japan their central bank has
more money on their balance sheet than
their entire GDP they're over 100% the
Japanese central money that's
interesting it's pretty crazy right yeah
once you go over a 50 percent you're
basically a socialistic society meaning
the government has more than 50 percent
of the economic output right right and
so we're at 30 percent now and literally
just food it just looks like we're going
vertical like we'll see what happens
we're at 6 trillion now my guess is that
we're gonna end up over 10 trillion
dollars when this is all said and done
some people think even higher than that
but if we ended up at over 10 trillion
dollars to be 2 and 1/2 x from when all
this started which would be absolutely
insane so let's get that money that
lunch money needs to go to real people
don't need to go to corporations don't
need to go to Wall should I need to go
to dead people
let's get in the hands of real people
cuz real people need help what's going
on draftkings draftkings one of the rare
companies that is choosing to pursue its
idea
in April it's a sports betting site and
is going public to a reverse merger all
right draftkings these guys are either
geniuses or idiots and I can't figure
out what
because what draftkings previously they
try to do torture and now they're saying
hey we're gonna actually go reverse
merger for those that don't know a
reverse merger basically is draftkings
wants to get under the public market but
they're not gonna go through a
traditional IPO process instead what
they do is they go find a company that
is public and they say just acquire us
and then when drag King gets flipped in
my guess is that the draftkings
executive team will take over running at
that new entity and it'll be the
combination of the existing business
called Diamond Eagle acquisition Corp
and the draft Kings business I tell them
my fundings polina one time I played
basketball with the draftkings executive
team in Madison Square Garden the best
part of this is that I went thinking
that I was going to a press conference
did not realize that I would have a
jersey and shoes and a basketball and
I'd be playing basketball with the team
in Madison Square Garden do you
understand how many men and women spend
their entire childhoods
dreaming of playing in Madison Square
Garden the mecca of basketball and our
lovely co-host and her bunny and them
playing in Madison Square Garden and it
was so ridiculous that afterwards she
called me she goes it was awesome we
were playing there was nobody in the
stands and even the tourists I were
taking tours of Madison Square Gardens
we're taking pictures almost like we
were famous a new one it's selfies I was
like I was stopping for selfies my team
was like hey like you need to be on this
side of the court like I don't know I
don't think I actually touched the ball
maybe I did like if somebody felt sorry
for me twice but otherwise I was just
running up and down the court in like
I'm sorry but trying to block big men
how do you even do that I was just like
and so I literally had to say to someone
hey can you please stop moving so I can
block you blocking that your guard
blocking means to slap the ball
definitely was not doing guarding that
means like not letting them get the ball
or not let it yeah can we also play an
anomaly play basketball at Madison
Square Garden one time but I also met
her once that she couldn't make a
hundred free-throws in two hours a
hundred fruits does not shoot a hundred
but actually make a hundred free throws
we did a practice session kind of and
she made like three in a half hour
and so I was like this is in the bag no
problem and then the day came and what
happened I did it in 39 minutes
you did it in 47 minutes but now I was
like 42 you see the fake news no I got
you guys but anyway so he didn't like 39
42 minutes and then you know why I did
it cuz when he was gone I was practicing
I was going everyday I was like if could
we can do this I can do this and then I
did it in 10 minutes anyway turtle
Walker again play McKee on with the
topics today so what the hell is a
turtle Walker so in Italy you're under
lockdown
you cannot go outside except if you have
a dog that you can walk so this amazing
woman apparently broke the law even
though I argue this is not really
breaking the law she had a turtle on a
leash that she was walking and she got
fine $440 why what's the difference
between a turtle and a dog well there's
a lot of differences between a turtle
and a dog to start one is normally ones
a normal pet ones not first of all
second of all it says a pizza size
turtle do you understand how big up
pizza is like that's on massive turtle
where she keeping that in her house and
third of all what are you doing with a
turtle on a leash you know what it
reminds me of it's like have you guys
seen the picture of tiger king where the
white Carroll basket it was [ __ ]
Carroll bastian chicken listen I can do
whatever I want
I'm making this [ __ ] up whatever and
then on top of that she's got the chain
and she's got Howard on the the tiger
thing what are you doing oh my god
so what happened she got a 400 so yes do
you think that she should get the farm
no because if you're allowed to walk
your big-ass dog I can walk my pizza
size turtle well you could argue that
dog needs exercise and dog needs to pee
but just a trailer pee why do you know
of turtles pee I'm sure they go to the
bathroom
but do they pee outside if this is a
well-trained turtle I'm sure no I bet
you add peas inside the turtle I need to
be outside get your ass back inside the
coronavirus anyway alright we appreciate
guys watching all week surprise
oh yeah just walk in my turtle is that
the woman no that's just it that's just
a little mean but like literally that's
probably what it looked like in the cop
was probably you're an idiot for having
a turtle pet like that that is literally
bigger than you so we're just gonna find
you $440 Joe didn't post a picture of me
all right guys we appreciate you guys
watching all week some free lunch money
this week rather than giving out cash to
do that last two weeks we are going to
give two separate people a free
subscription to the newsletter I write
every week or every day I guess and the
newsletter that Polina writes so telling
about the profile real quick the profile
is the best newsletter on the Internet
it comes out every Sunday morning at 703
am much more consistent than our friends
newsletter over here and it features
profiles of the most interesting and
successful people and companies on the
Internet sign up read the profile calm
and as soon as I want to give her
actually really liked it and I read a
newsletter every single morning covering
finance economics crypto whatever
basically I want to write about and so
what you have to do to win is take the
URL to this video and you've got to
tweet it with the one thing you learned
this week we will go through and we will
pick two people and then we will give
each of you free subscriptions to both
of them which is like so how much you
charge for yours I don't know - $10 a
month or $50 a year but you'll get it
for free I didn't know that I had a
or Qatar here with me I appreciate that
so leave us some comments let us know
what you guys think about this episode
tweet the URL with the one thing you
learned this week and we will give two
people a free subscription to the
newsletter any parting words for the
people while you don't see them for the
next two days so one be kind to your
friends and for all my friends from
Eastern Europe Happy Easter you would
you literally look like a wannabe lens
with why young people wanna be Instagram
influencers who's taking pictures and
posting it on their Instagram account we
pastels hoping for an extra couple or
Ronnie the reason I'm wearing have you
ever seen me wear the shirt before no
you ever seen me wear this shirt before
yes I have nothing else to wear do
laundry no no I mean like no I mean like
different types of clothing on so cuz
you know in the comments that be like
well you know we saw that last week yeah
or you could be like me they're like yo
pop you wear the same hat shirt every
single day and I'm like you guys don't
even know if I washed it or not tell
them about the shorts today's the first
day I haven't worn sweat pants shorts in
three weeks big occasion I went outside
no problem
alright guys bang bang we'll see you
next week while while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right twelve o'clock
everyday see you soon